[Musique]
je présente en deux minutes
carole perrin c'est elle qui introduira
jean-marc airfoil en plus de son poste
cnjc partie du comité développement de
notre fondation et coordonne le groupe
kiss au développement durable qui va
mettre en valeur et parler l'école pour
toute la partie développement durable
donc je peux te laisser carole le dire
deux mots sur son rôle et essayer de
débloquer mais cela aide pendant ce
temps d'accord merci et sandrine encore
une fois bienvenue à tous et merci de
votre participation à cette conférence
on vous redire en deux mots le rôle de
la fondation vous le savez c'est d'aider
au développement de l'école et
effectivement j'ai le plaisir d'animer
avec quelques complices camarades de
mathias martin robert bringue jean luc
laurent elie antoine battistelli un
petit groupe pour développer tout lax
développement durable des actions de
l'école va donc rendre visible en fait
et aider toutes les actions que mène
l'école matière de développement durable
que ce soit sur les actions
d'enseignement et de recherche mais
aussi de diffusion des connaissances
voilà faire progresser la connaissance
donc là c'est vraiment tout ce que font
les équipes de recherche les chairs les
projets scientifiques faire en sorte que
la fondation puisse soutenir ces projets
développer la connaissance on va y
revenir et puis développé d'exemplarité
aussi de l'école faire en sorte que
l'école soit elle-même un lieu
évidemment manifestement durable et vous
savez qu'on a eu la bonne nouvelle en
début d'année de voir l'école retenu
parmi tous les projets que à soutenir
l'état pour la rénovation des bâtiments
publics de l'état et donc un gros projet
de 18 millions d'euros qui vient d'être
lancé pour pour aider à cette rénovation
est donc la fondation continuera à
accompagner l'école aussi pour que cette
tout ce projet puis 7
n'est parfait jusqu'à son terme et ça va
être un projet parfaite vraiment
exemplaire sur l'aspect qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui c'est l'as fait
diffuser les connaissances
ça nous semblait important de d'appuyer
aussi tout ce que peut faire l'école
pour faire connaître partager l'état de
larve savait que notre école a comme
slogan théorie et pratique et c'est
important de se confronter m ces
théories à jour est confronté aussi avec
la pratique et donc qui de mieux
aujourd'hui pour parler de ces sujets là
que jean marc jean marc jancovici que je
vais présenter rapidement mais vous avez
vu connaissez sans doute déjà son
pedigree d'ailleurs je vais très vite au
site
interrogé un peu sur ton parcours
jean-marc mais peut-être dire en deux
mots que c'est un je te remercie
vraiment beaucoup de ta présence ce soir
tu es professeur à l'école depuis 2008
et tu es membre du haut conseil pour le
climat je rappelle que c'est au conseil
a été créé par dans la république en
2018 que tu as été nommé avec d'autres
membres éminents qui sont des
spécialistes ce sujet de du
réchauffement climatique avec une vue
assez interdisciplinaire et d'ailleurs
avec aussi sophie dubuisson quellier qui
est docteur en sociologie de l'école des
mines de paris et maintenant professeur
au cnrs
donc j'en tue et associé fondateur de
carbone 4 tu as créé aussi de gip
projette en fait ça fait plus de vingt
ans que tu es très engagé sur ce sujet
de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
on va avoir l'occasion de débattre avec
toi des questions importantes justement
du rôle des ingénieurs en vis-à-vis de
ces enjeux du réchauffement climatique
et je voulais peut-être commencer par
une question d'ouverture pour que tu
nous redisent dans ton parcours
personnel
comment ça commence comment sais tu es
venu à ces questions là comment tu as
été finalement quels ont été les
éléments fondateurs de ton engagement
sur cette question épineuse du cycle du
carbone
en fait ça a été un mélange de ça a été
un mélange de hasard il ya beaucoup de
hasards dans sa danse est dans ce qui
m'est arrivé
comme beaucoup de jeunes diplômés
peut-être à la sortie de l'école en fait
j'avais pas du tout envie d'être
ingénieur
ouais je vais pas jusqu'à dire que je
dire c'était un gros mot mais enfin je
suis j'ai été diplômé à la fin des
années 80 fois au milieu des années 80 à
une époque où on ne peut pas dire que
l'ingénieur était vraiment ce qui était
considéré comme étant le summum du de la
delà de ce qui faisait briller les yeux
des dames pour moi c'était quand même
mieux d'être chanteur à succès financier
ou autre chose et je suis arrivé sur le
sujet du changement climatique alors
totalement par hasard à la fin des
années 90 à une époque où comme école
dacquois prédictions d'école d'appli
j'ai fait les télécoms est donc dans le
courant des années 90 j'ai pas mal
travaillé dans tout ce qui est l
émergence des téléservices donc les
trucs qui sont aujourd'hui devenus une
réalité
par exemple ce qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment là c'est ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler du virtuel en fait du
numérique c'est à lui maintenant d'usagé
courant de travailler de se divertir
d'enseigner à la fin des années 90
c'était pas du tout courant est en fait
à l'époque l'ancêtre d'orange donc
s'appeler france télécom réfléchissait à
la manière dans ce genre de choses
pouvaient se diffuser et si en fait en
travaillant sur ce genre de sujet que je
suis tombé sur la question du changement
climatique via l'enchaînement suivant
qui était ce genre de télé services
peuvent éviter des déplacements éviter
des déplacements ça évite des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et là j'ai vu
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre je
suis qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc là
et en fait j'ai commencé à dévider le
fil de cette pelote alors à cette époque
là j'étais consultant indépendant
gt gt dans un domaine où les affaires
marchent moins bien qu'aujourd'hui au
sens où j'avais le client était un peu
plus à aller chercher avec les dents
sarkozy donc j'avais un peu de temps
libre et donc j'ai commencé à enseigner
à me documenter pour voir ce que c'était
que ce truc là et c'est à cette époque
là finalement que j'ai redécouvert
l'intérêt des études que j'avais fait
quinze ans après donc gg
j'ai mis longtemps avant finalement de
mettre à profit d'une manière que je
trouvais pas de 80 ce que j'avais plus
qu'avant je trouvais que ce qu'on
enseignait était pas suffisamment relié
à des questions sociétales par les deux
consoeurs
c'est comme ça qu'on dit du haut conseil
pour le climat tout à l'heure des
questions sociales sociétales enfin de
ski de ce qui fait un peu vibrer le
coeur des hommes
moi je trouvais que c'était très loin et
là je retombais dans un domaine dans
lequel il y avait la possibilité de
trois ailes ou même d'interpeller très
les disciplines c'est à dire de ceux de
d'avoir une préoccupation d'ingénieurs
met au service de quelque chose qui
était beaucoup plus large et donc
beaucoup plus excitant voilà alors après
donc ça ça a été de la chance parce que
j'aurais pu ne pas tomber dessus et puis
cette époque-là on enseigne est pas ce
sujet on les échos non alors on
enseignait pas et surtout l'enseignement
que j'ai reçus alix comme dans beaucoup
d'autres écoles d'ingénieurs était quand
même très très déconnecté des
préoccupations sociétales d'une manière
générale c'est à dire que l'équation de
schrödinger avant de pouvoir la relier
aux rencontres aspirations de et aux
grandes émotions des animaux que nous
sommes il faut quand même se lever de
bonne heure
donc voilà donc aimer à ce moment là
encore une fois j'ai fait un lien c'est
à dire que c'est tout c'est tout c'est
mater cette physique aride alors qu'il
pouvait avoir une forme de beauté
esthétique en elle même de temps en
temps
mais qu'ils étaient des disciplines un
peu en vase clos j'ai réussi à les
raccrocher à quelque chose qui était
beaucoup plus intéressant puisqu'il
était question de l'avenir des hommes
l'avenir de l'humanité et donc notamment
tu as été quand même le le fondateur de
carbone 4 et donc l'inventeur du bilan
carbone donc une méthode que tu as voilà
définie fin mis en place promu ensuite
pour qu'on soit tous finalement dans les
activités humaines dans les activités
des entreprises capables de
d'appréhender notre impact carbone est
ce que tu peux peut-être rappeler
rapidement
déjà ce comment ça marche un bilan
carbone peut-être que certaines nos
camarades sont pas encore complètement
flux intense combinant carbone même si
est normalement ce copain scott the
scope 3 ça devrait parler à plus en plus
de monde et puis peut-être la génèse
aussi comment ça s'est progressivement
mis en place dans le village le bilan
carbone il est né justement de cette
observation que j'ai eu à l'époque au
début des années 2000 le changement
climatique est dans une posture qui est
très particulière c'est à dire qu'il ya
à la fois des gens qui connaissent le
sujet depuis longtemps et on peut relire
des notes
par exemple il ya des documents
remarquable du non moins remarquable il
martin qui date des années 90 voire 2990
ya rien à rajouter aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce qu'il écrivait à l'époque
il y avait un certain nombre de
précurseur déjà 1990 il y avait un
certain de précurseur déjà qui avait
fait le tour de la question tout compris
mais enfin l'immense majorité n'en était
pas là et surtout dans le monde de
l'entreprise on n'était pas du tout
capable de commencer à s'attaquer aux
sujets et donc le bilan carbone son
principe c'est que c'est le plan
comptable sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donc en gros une
entreprise elle a un plan comptable pour
les euros d'achat les vents
et bien sûr le changement qui efface sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
lui fallait un plan comptable est en
fait le plan comptable que j'ai dit au
point inventorie les sources dont une
activité dépend et non pas une active de
les sources dont une activité
responsable donc ce qui m'intéressait à
l'époque ce n'était pas une notion de
détention juridique
c'était une notion de couverture contre
le risque à partir du moment où on
dépend de quelque chose on est à risque
si ce quelque chose n'existe plus quand
bien même on est strictement pas
responsable ou pas détenteur sur le plan
juridique
si je prends un exemple si renault vend
des voitures à essence et que demain
matin il est interdit aux gens qui ont
des voitures à essence d'acheter de
l'essence
renault peut tout à fait dire ou totale
que tout à fait dire c'est pas moi
monsieur parce que c'est pendant qu'ils
achètent les sens des automobilistes
c'est parfaitement vrai juridiquement
ils sont absolument pas propriétaire de
ses émissions en attendant si elles ne
peuvent plus survenir
donc là c'était exactement le dessin le
principe c'était et le scope 3 c'est
tout ce qui est en dehors du périmètre
juridique d'une entreprise mais dont ses
activités dépendance que dans un jargon
économique on pourrait appeler les
émissions de cherchell de valeur donc le
ce copain pour redire peut-être pour
tout le monde c'est des émissions
directes sans vraiment lié uniquement de
nuit ici c'est le scope 2c des émissions
liées à la consommation d'énergie qu'on
a pu avoir quitté pas forcément
directement sur le site mais qui sont
liées aux consommations d'énergie du
process et puis le scope 3 c'est
effectivement finalement la consommation
d'énergie les érections
ils sont qui sont faites sur tout le
cycle de vie du produit donc depuis les
fournisseurs jusqu'aux ensuite les
utilisateurs du produit et les cv pour
l'essentiel des entreprises c'est
l'essentiel des émissions alors je
trouve que à l'époque où j'ai fait de
bilan carbone pour l'ademe
il y avait une initiative qui est né aux
états unis qui s'appelait le ghg
protocol et donc j'ai vécu alors ça je
me permets de le dire quand même j'ai
vécu une opération de super l'opération
de captation d'héritage
c'est à dire que le ghg protocol a été
fait par des gens qui sont il ya 40
autour de la table et donc quand on se
met à 40 autour de la table l'expérience
enseigne que
il n'en sort jamais rien d' extrêmement
structurants ce que les gens se mettent
d'accord sur un truc jamais très
dispositif
moi je travaillais tout seul dans la
cave avec l'ademe et en fait les gens du
ghg protocol avait juste mis au point
ces notions de ce copain de 3 mais rien
de plus
alors que de notre côté avec le bilan
carbone on a mis au point le plan
comptable c'est à dire on va
individualiser les émissions liées aux
déplacements des salariés les émissions
liées aux déplacements achat des
matières premières les émissions liées
aux déplacements professionnels et c est
dans le cadre du groupe de discussion à
l'iso qui devait définir la norme
d'application delà de la norme donnant
les prescriptions pour les inventaires
d'émissions des entretiens des
organisations telles des entreprises il
y avait à la fois les gens du grj
protocole et l'ademe les gens du village
et protocoles ont vu le travail du bilan
carbone il sait très bien ce truc là et
ils ont appelé ça le ghg protocol supply
chain est en fait le boulot que j'ai
fait est passé à la postérité avec le
tampon ghg protocol
alors ça m'a beaucoup peiné hve et ce
qui m'a beaucoup peiné à l'époque ça je
vais me permettre de le dire parce que
c'est un grand enseignement que j'en ai
tiré c'est que la france meurt d'être un
village gaulois trop souvent et il ya un
certain nombre de cas de figure et en ce
moment on est en train de le revivre
dans d'autres domaines
une faute d'arriver à se mettre d'accord
entre nous sur des trucs intelligents
ont fini par se faire imposer des abris
venus de l'extérieur
je pense que dans le domaine du
changement climatique
on n'est pas les plus mal parti en
termes de méthodes de normes et de façon
d'avancer est que la dernière des
âneries affaire particulièrement quand
on est deux côtés des pouvoirs publics
c'est d'écouter des acteurs qui
gémissent un peu trop fort pour
entériner des abris et malheureusement
on continue à faire ce genre et à ce
moment c'est les américains qui arrivent
et qui nous disent on va faire comme ça
et puis une fois sur deux du reste ils
ne font pas le même
c'est aussi comme ça qu'on a fini par
récupérer les intéresse donc le
donc je mets c'était un c'était vraiment
un point important alors ça n'a pas du
tout empêché la méthode de se répandre
j'ai zéro problème d'ego entre que ce
soit estampillé ghg protocol jean-paul
ici je m'en fiche complètement
par contre j'en ai vraiment retenu la
leçon que la france dans les batailles
de dorment des fois n'est pas du tout à
la hauteur des enjeux
et ça c'est un message que j'ai très
envie de passer ce soir parce qu'il ya
un certain nombre de gens autour de la
wiener que ça concerne directement
voilà donc voilà ce à quoi s'est
resserrée bilan carbone alors en 2007
après avoir fait du bilan carbone
enfin avant mise au point et avoir fait
du bilan carbone tout seul dans mon coin
j'ai cofondé car votre 4 avec un autre
technicien qui s'appelle alain grandjean
qui est aussi aujourd'hui au conseil
pour le climat on s'est retrouvés et
carbone4 mis en oeuvre en fin dé a
démarré par du bilan carbone et puis
aujourd'hui on fait tout un tas d'autres
trucs qui sont les étapes après j'ai
également en 2010 un fonds d un film
tank laboratoire d'idées pas comment il
rappelé a exactement qui s'appelle de
chiffres project alors lui a donné un
nom anglais parce que on a toujours eu
l'espoir fou un de finir par monter au
niveau européen donc c'est pour ça qu'on
lui a donné un nom anglais depuis des
bars et qui est une association
essentiellement financée par des
entreprises et qui milite pour la
décarbonation de l'économie donc j'ai et
puis en 2008 si ma mémoire est bonne
[Musique]
l'école des mines enfin mines paristech
m'a proposé de faire un court 2
milliards isation j'ai été très étonné
par le processus parce que en gros alors
bon je pense qu'on n'a pas tout dit je
pense que quand il ya des gens pour
regarder d'un peu près ce que je
racontais qui ont vérifié que je disais
pas trop de conneries mais enfin le
souvenir que j'en ai c'est que ça s'est
fait sur un coin de table lors d'un
déjeuner avec le directeur des études et
qui m'a demandé si j'étais d'accord pour
faire un court je dis bien volontiers
et en fait c'est un cours que je fais
toujours avec beaucoup de plaisir parce
que je trouve que c'est très gratifiant
d'enseigner en particulier quand les
élèves font l'effort de venir le matin
et d'écouté donc si je résume jean-marc
tu allais un ingénieur du 21ème siècle
qui a découvert dans les années 2000 les
enjeux du 21e siècle donc de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique qui a
mis sa logique d'ingénieurs e au service
d'un outil comptable d'économistes de
carbone pour aujourd'hui diffusée
largement au niveau international un
mondial comme tu l'as dit ce sujet de la
comptabilité carbone et revenir aussi
maintenant à l'école aux fondamentaux
pour diffuser auprès des ingénieurs du
21e siècle
formé au 21e siècle en tout cas le
justement lit les fondamentaux de des
cycles du carbone et au delà de 5 2 des
enjeux de finalement de d'écosystèmes
d'un écosystème physique et ils vivent
c'est peut-être ça nous c'est cette
introduction qui nous a permis de voir
tout ton parcours est d'atteindre je
dirai ce que la question qui est celle
de deux lacs au titre de cette
conférence du coup qu'elles sont fort de
ceux de cette expérience aujourd'hui toi
tes messages sur le rôle que peuvent
jouer doivent jouer les ingénieurs
aujourd'hui contenu de 7,7 de cette
donne de cette transition écologique
énergétique sociétale
qui est en cours sans parler du
introduite au parcours parce a aussi un
autre concession numérique qui
évidemment nous permettent d'ailleurs
heureusement aujourd'hui de tenir cette
conférence si on essaye de remettre un
tout petit peu en perspective le métier
d'ingénieur en fait c'est un métier qui
est relativement récent c'est un métier
qui est apparue avec la révolution
industrielle
on va dire et donc c'est un métier qui
est lié au fait d'arriver à tirer le
meilleur parti de des ressources
naturelles que nous sommes capables de
puiser dans l'environnement du reste
mines paristech et l'école des mines
voit bien ce que ça formait les
ingénieurs qui étaient chargés de tirer
le meilleur parti des ressources
minérales et fossiles que l'on pourrait
trouver dans le sous sol
alors moi j'ai coutume de dire
maintenant que le métier de l'ingénieur
c'est de faire de l'optimisation sous
contrainte et qu' il doit rejoindre au
niveau des contraintes les grands enjeux
sociétaux du 21e siècle et y en a un qui
est absolument majeur qui est le fait
que la terre n'a pas envie d'augmenter
de diamètre en même temps que la
population augmente donc on a un tout
petit sujet à gérer qui est d'arriver à
faire tenir tout le monde sur une
planète qui n'augmentent pas de diamètre
et où pour le moment le mode de vie que
nous avons dépend essentiellement d'une
exploitation linéaire de ressources en
matière d'énergie par exemple la
deuxième loi de la thermodynamique nous
dit que l'on saura jamais faire
d'exploitation circulaire de l'énergie
revient donc il ya une exploitation
libère des ressources et en particulier
de l'énergie qui est malheureusement non
durables donc le l'ingénieur du 21e
siècle
il a un nouveau genre d'optimisation
sont contraints a pas inventé
l'optimisation c'est ce que fait qu'on
se tape pas dessus et qu'on soit plutôt
content de se lever le matin et la
contrainte c'est que on peut pas
continuer comme avant parce que ça ne
tient plus dans la ouate tendance il
faut il faut pouvoir décarbonés il faut
pouvoir se développer sans carbone
décarbonés il faut des métallisé aussi
parce qu'il ya un certain nombre de
métaux
dans l'enceinte des mines si ma mémoire
est bonne la première mine de cuivre qui
a exploité par ri à rio tinto justement
est le descendant à la compagnie par
ailleurs en espagne avait une teneur en
cuivre dans le minerai qui était de
l'ordre de 18 de 16 à 18%
aujourd'hui la teneur en cuivre moyenne
dans le minerai 0 5%
le maximum des captures en mer a eu lieu
en 1995
ça fait donc 25 ans les gens qui
rentrent à l'école des mines aujourd'hui
enfin me paraît jamais aujourd'hui sont
nés après le maximum des captures en l2
puis les capturant verte etc lille parce
que les stocks sont surexploités voilà
qui pourrait donner plein d'exemples
donc le décarbonés l'économie oui c'est
un enjeu c'est mon enjeux professionnels
centrale et j'ai pas de raison d'aller
s'aventurer sur le docteur mais il
n'empêche que ça n'est pas le seul enjeu
est que en fait quand on regarde ce qui
se passe pour l'actif naturel qui
s'appelle la planète terre et tout ce
qui se trouvait dessus ça s'érode de
tous les côtés encore une fois pas que
la question du climat qui est qui et
dans cette affaire donc l'ingénieur du
21e siècle
sa tâche s'ils l'acceptent comme dans
mission impossible est du reste ce sera
pour partie du surplus ce type va être
de faire en sorte que l'on n'ait un
atterrissage en douceur à 8 10 900 je ne
sais pas combien de milliards sur terre
sur une terre qui sera beaucoup moins
bien doté que celle qu'on a trouvé les
deux siècles parce qu'il ya une bonne
partie du capital naturel qu'on a
consommé on a consommé depuis
alors c'est un peu ça en le message que
j'essaie de passer
j'essaye pardon de passer à mes élèves
alors je le concède volontiers qu'il ya
un côté très douche froide dans cette
affaire je les prends ils ont 20 ans
ils ont la vie devant eux puis je leur
dis vous allez avoir à passer le balai
d'ailleurs une partie de ce qu'on a fait
mais je pense aussi que c'est de là
qu'on peut faire naître des vocations et
qu'on peut justement leur éviter ce qui
moi m'a fait défaut quand je suis sortie
d'école c'est à dire de voir dans ce
métier toute la noblesse qu'il peut
avoir quand il est lié au service d'une
grande cote est aujourd hui je trouve
qu'on n'en souffre un peu alors
évidemment de dire les choses comme ça
ça oblige aussi à faire le tri oblige
aussi à dire ou même un baigneur vous
savez si vous allez faire du compte pour
faire des algorithmes de trading haute
fréquence peut-être que vous n'êtes pas
aussi utile à la société que si vous
allez essayer de regarder comment est ce
qu'on peut se déplacer en n'émettant pas
de co2 mais je pense quand même que
l'heure est venue où il est revenu de
d'inspirer les jeunes ingénieurs pour
qu'ils aient envie de se mettre au
service de causes sociétales et une
bonne partie d'entre eux le réclament il
ya qu à voir en ce moment ce qui se
passe avec par exemple le manifeste pour
un réveil écologique des étudiants où je
vois le taux de signature de se balader
entre 30 et 60% comme dans toutes les
écoles d'ingénieurs bon alors il ya ce
qu'ils disaient ce qu'ils font mais
quand même ça montre bien qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une vraie désir qu'il ya et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'enseignement
n'a pas encore totalement fini d'opérer
sa mue
alors je sais que vincent laflèche je
connais bien amusé nos fonds de culotte
la même année au même endroit et très
convaincus du fait qu'il faut partir
dans cette direction et je pense que les
mines n'ont pas à rougir de ce que l'eau
ce qui s'y passe parce que je pense que
c'est un des établissements qui est
plutôt aux avant postes
de ce point de vue mais je pense que les
écoles d'ingénieurs dans leur ensemble
dans ce pays n'ont pas pu y d'opérer
leur transformation pour remettre au
service de quelque chose et ne pas être
comme la banque centrale et sa politique
monétaire totalement neutres vis-à-vis
de l'économie
et justement alors qu'elles sont selon
toi les disciplines les enseignements ou
les expériences de stage parce que c'est
aussi une de ses forces de l'école et
que l'ingénieur c'est de confronter
aussi au monde de l'entreprise au monde
justement des acteurs économiques
quelles sont les disciplines qui te
semble importante dans une école
généraliste justement où je pense que
c'est sans doute une des chances
justement de nos écoles d'être à la fois
des écoles d'ingénieurs certes mais
aussi où sont enseignés et les sujets de
sociologie d'innovation dans l'économie
une certaine ouverture justement aux
enjeux socio-économiques que tu écrivais
iard plein il ya probablement plein de
choses qui sont pas de temps a changé
que ça savoir résoudre une équation
différentielle ça sera utile à plein de
gens dans plein de domaines
par contre dans les géants veut dire les
quelque chose qu'il ait quelque chose
qui me paraissent absolument essentiel
c'est d'essayer d'avoir en train de fond
toujours pourquoi on fait les choses
c'est à dire en toute chose il faut voir
la fin donc c'est quoi la finalité de ce
qu'on enseigne
c'est probablement à voir également en
permanence la capacité à distinguer les
faits d opinion dès lors qu'on sort des
purs moulinette
j'ai envie de dire physiques et
mathématiques qui sont une boîte à
outils un alors la physique car est
quand même plus de comprendre le monde
mathématiques c'est vraiment moi je
pense que les esprits
pardon là où il ya le plus de là où il
ya le plus de changements à opérer les
plages de taches noires ainsi quelques
dents c'est dans l'économie parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'économie qu'on enseigne
quand même une économie qui est basé sur
des conventions qui sont de plus en plus
déconnectés de l'ariège
et donc là je pense qu'on enseigne tout
bêtement de choses fausses ont regardé
fait un regard du monde physique
c'est quand même c'est quand même
ennuyeux il ya également quelque chose
qui est alors je sais pas si ça relève
de l'enseignement mais en tout cas ça
peut relever de la méthode qui est de
savoir faire des approches en ordre de
grandeur dès qu'on rentre dans des
problèmes pratiques
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
permet de faire cas très vite le tri
entre ce qui peut fonctionner un jour
est-ce qu'il ya très peu de chances de
parvenir au but visé
donc peut-être qu'il ya un côté à partir
du moment où on se dit qu'on doit
retrouver un doit pouvoir accrocher tout
cet enseignement à des visées ou à des
aspirations sociétal pense pas qu'il
faille tout changer de fond en comble il
ya déjà des idées et des poux encore une
fois je pense que le domaine dans lequel
il ya le plus à changer probablement
c'est le domaine de l'économie aux
ingénieurs de l'économie c'est une
convention s'est passé s'est pas basée
sur des faits s'est basé sur des
conventions et donc il faut savoir
garder énormément de hauteur de vue
vis-à-vis des notions qu'on manipule les
indices par exemple qu'on habille
disparaîtra avec les hommes
disparaîtront la loi conservation de
l'énergie sont toujours là donc le voilà
c'est ça qu'il faut à mon avis qui
manque aujourd'hui dans l'enseignement
et l'économie ne connaît pas de loi elle
connaît des conventions donc je vais en
vue de tester jean-marc sur sur un avis
a peut-être un peu personnel mais qui
est aussi le fruit de mon retour
d'expérience et de de trouver que en
tant qu'ingénieur on a comme un complexe
vis-à-vis du sujet du vivant je pense
aux vivants alors non seulement les
êtres humains je crois que à travers les
questions de sociologie du monde de
l'entreprise sociale ont l'impression et
du vivant sous sa forme la plus simple
qui va depuis le virus ont tous un peu
mieux ce que c'est aujourd'hui un virus
ou bactéries pour revenir quand même à
l'origine de la vie et aujourd'hui au
sujet que qui nous passionne du
développement durable c'est-à-dire de
reprendre aussi conscience que
si on respire aujourd'hui c'est grâce à
des algues qui pendant des millions
d'années ont fait leur petit travail de
photosynthèse et reprendre tous
conscience que finalement l'énergie que
l'on est en capacité de l'utiliser sur
la planète c'est celle qui vient de
soleil et qui est d'abord transformé par
les êtres vivants qui sont des ags où on
a beau dire super héros donc c'est fait
je voulais ton avis là dessus parce que
d'ailleurs dans tes ailes et du haut
conseil pour le climat il ya aussi
beaucoup de biologistes je pense à
monsieur jean-françois soussana ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent du monde
de la biologie d'agronomes de 2 pour
comprendre le sujet de l'écologie qui
est ce cycle en fait de la matière et de
l'énergie mais qui passe non seulement
par des lois physiques mais aussi par
quand même des phénomènes assez
particulier que permettent le vivant et
qui parfois ont étonné les ingénieurs
qui ne soupçonnent pas toujours que ce
que peut faire une bactérie alors qu une
bactérie semble parfois défié les lois
de la physique
donc ça est ce que dans nos formations
d'ingénieurs cette capacité à mieux
appréhender les phénomènes vivent donc
de biologie l'écologie n'est pas aussi
une un sujet qui viendraient enrichir
notre compréhension du monde
suite aux événements alors pour moi dans
les ingénieurs il ya les ingénieurs du
vivant donc ça dépend de ce qu'on
appelle ingénieurs
mines paristech en forme plutôt de ce
que j'appellerais des ingénieurs de
l'inerte c'est à dire des gens qui
savent ce que c'est que le faire la
houille et puis un peu derrière les
moteurs et numérique il ya aussi toute
la filière en france des ingénieurs du
vivant la france dans sa grande bonté
amour des nomenclatures à séparer les
deux c'est à dire que les ingénieurs du
vivant d'un côté on a les agronomes les
gens qui font de la bio y avait l'autre
côté des gens qui font des maths et de
la physique mais c'est clair qu'on
gagnerait à ce que les intras un peu de
l'autre et les autres fassent un peu de
la manche quand j'étais non pas prof de
tronc commun aux mines mais que j'étais
prof d'options l'option concurrente de
la mienne était une option de biologie
et ça me désole parce que j'étais à la
fois très content que les élèves
viennent à mon cours est très valeureux
de les avoir empêchés de suivre un cours
de biologie dont je me disais mais c'est
important ce truc là aussi donc c'est
dommage qu'ils aient à choisir entre les
deux on leur demande de choisir entre
deux sujets qui sont des sujets
importants qui sont d'un côté comprendre
le monde du vivant et de l'autre côté
comprendre de quoi il retourne quand on
parle du changement climatique et de
notre dépendance à l'énergie
je me disais c'est vraiment dommage
voilà donc la même pièce si les deux
faces de la même pièce
je suis très content de plus avoir ses
états d'âme ses l'abordage d'être basés
entre commun mais oui c'est certain que
et puis alors il ya un autre phénomène
lié aux vivants quand on s'y prend bien
et que l'enseignant est bon c'est que ça
développe chez nous des capacité
d'émerveillement et souvent
l'émerveillement engendre l'envi de
respecter quelque chose
donc c'est ça aussi une vertu à ce titre
moi je suis tout à fait favorable
la place pour voilà mes donc si on
enlève un peu de macroéconomie je
pleurais pas ok peut-être propose une
petite dernière question avant d'ouvrir
les questions donc je me retourne vers
sandrine pour voir comment vous voulez
qu'on fasse mais l'ours soit voulez vous
pouvez mettre vos questions sur le chat
ou ont commencé pour le chat donc je
propose de les lire ensuite peut-être
voilà donc c'est pour que ce soit le
plus interactive possible et peut-être
du coup question pour puisque tu as dit
tout à l'heure que que pour
l'enseignement donné une première grande
claque quand tu fait appréhender ces
enjeux du réchauffement climatique et
sont effectivement dans la conclusion
est qu'il faut que quelque chose change
qu'il faut qu'on change de mode de vie
qu'on change des solutions pour pouvoir
vivre sans impacter l'environnement et
même comme tu l'as dit ça devrait
générer pour les générations futures et
du coup qu'elles sont aujourd'hui on
connaît toutes les difficultés du sujet
et des frustrations qu'on peut avoir sur
le sujet mais qu'est ce qui te donne toi
le plus d'espoir pour qu'on réussisse à
répondre à ce défi
alors les jeunes ils ont un jordan blake
ils ont un atout extraordinaire c'est
qu'ils sont jeunes et donc il ya une
très belle définition de la jeunesse que
j'aime beaucoup qui est
on déjeune temps qu'on se croyait
éternelle est invincible donc c'est
j'aime bien donc
donc oui ils prennent une grosse claque
et puis après ils s'enlèvent parce
qu'ils sont jeunes parce que c'est des
gens qui ont cédé sur ces des survivants
quelque part dire que les gens qui
arrivent aux mines c'est quand même des
gens qui ont survécu c'est un survécu à
deux ans de prépa donc lyon turin tout
petit peu il ya une ennemie avec quelque
part il ya innover lui ils ont raison je
ne voudrais pas que je croise pas aux
damnés de la terre dont je fini
d'enfoncer la tête sous l'eau je sais
très bien que je m'adresse à des gens
qui au contraire vont finir par rebondir
du reste on le voit bien j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure du manifeste pour un réveil
écologique c'est exactement ça c'est à
dire que c'est le ressort qui se détend
après avoir été compris mais parce qu'on
a affaire à des gens qui ont du ressort
parce qu'on a affaire à des gens qui
croient en leurs capacités confiance
dans les jeunes générations des mineurs
alors j'ai confiance dans le fait que
c'est des gens qui sont capables de
surmonter le petit coup de déprime
initiales liées à la claque qu'ils ont
reçu oui ça j'ai tout à fait confiance
dans sa part ailleurs j'ai tout à fait
confiance dans le fait que pour bien
traiter un problème il faut l'avoir
correctement définis et que le
changement climatique est dans une forme
de course contre la montre si on
commence par perdre du temps à définir
le problème de travers ce que ce que
nous adorons faire une fois qu'on est
dans les luttes d'intérêts dans le monde
réel on est à peu près sûr de pas à pas
résoudre le problème est donc le pré va
se résoudre à nos dépens parce qu'à
aucun moment on aura accepté de le
définir correctement
donc je suis je ne suis pas du tout
pessimiste sur l'envié de s'engager
d'une bonne partie des gens à qui je
dispense mon enseignement ça je suis pas
du tout pessimiste là dessus la bonne
question après c'est qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent faire de cette énergie
parce que changer le monde ça se fait
pas en 15 secondes et puis par
définition ça c'est machiavel qui nous
avaient très bien expliquer ça les gros
et puissants du moment sont ceux qui ont
réussi avec les règles du jeu du passé
et donc c'est justement ce qui n'ont
strictement aucune envie que les règles
du jeu changent
or ces cgc chez ces gens là pardon qui
lie à la place puis
c'est eux qui sont gros c'est eux qui
embauche c'est eux qui etc alors ça
change un peu aussi je me rappelle que
matthieu mazière m'a montré il ya
quelques années une statistique à un
angle de dans une statistique sur la
part des jeunes diplômés qui choisissait
un grand groupe pour leur premier emploi
et cette part est descendu de 60 à 30 %
en l'espace de quelques années et donc
ça à mon avis c'est très symptomatiques
de ce désir d'engagement c'est à dire
qu'une partie croissante des propos se
reconnaissent pas dans les plans de
carrière pour leur propose dans les
grosses boîtes parce qu'ils disent c'est
pas ça que j'ai envie de faire ça
correspond pas au monde de demain dans
lequel j'ai envie de vivre et donc ils
vont ailleurs alors ils vont pas
nécessairement dans les start up et pme
et je pense qu'ils ont envie puisque
sinon il n'y aurait pas tenter
l'aventuré ailleurs que dans des
sentiers balisés
je pense qu'ils agissent parce que sinon
des mouvements spontanés comme le
manifeste étudiants n'existerait pas la
question s'est il faut arriver à
canaliser cette énergie pour qu'ils
arrivent à en faire quelque chose de
constructif et dont ils diront pas dans
cinq ou dix ans à merde je suis parti
dans une mauvaise voie parce que j'avais
pas encore fini de bien comprendre le
problème
voilà c'est ça c'est ça le csii point
important me semble-t-il
où est ce qu'ils perçoivent comme un
pari peu ils peuvent agir un peu un peu
un peu partout et façon il n'ya jamais
de recette miracle quand on décide de
passer à l'action par contre il ya eu il
ya une vérité c'est que l'action rend
optimiste donc en fait les gens qui
reçoivent la douche froide
et puis qui se met dans une logique de
s'attaquer au problème
de toute façon leur moral se mêler à un
lieu superbe donc on a déjà un plein de
questions et dont d'ailleurs une
première offre de services de samuel qui
dit je suis formé aux mines j'étudie
depuis trois ans le métier de chef de
choeur avec vous des idées deux moyens
de mettre double compétence au service
de la transition énergétique
by ap les médecins ça dépend s'il veut
vivre de son métier de chef de choeur ou
pas
nécessairement par l urd ok si ça reste
un loisir à partir de 18 heures on est
comme comme selon une maxime célèbre à
ramener au point que précédent c'est à
dire que en fait ça devient juste une
demande au géant médias classiques il ya
quelques mois au sein des chiffres alors
le shit project est une association
d'entreprises mais il s'est constitué à
côté du chiffre project un mouvement une
association qui s'appelle le shifters et
qui en fait regroupe toutes les
personnes physiques qui ont envie de
prêter main forte aux travaux du chiffre
project ou de soutenir la cause de l'eau
etc
et alors c'est des gens qui foisonne
d'idées et ils en ont misé une au point
il ya quelques mois qui est d'avoir
recensés sur un site qui s'appelle shift
sur job
toutes les entités qui sont susceptibles
de correspondre peu ou prou à quelque
chose d'utile pour la décarbonation
d'économie alors on y trouve à la fois
des gens qui loue des vélos et les f
il ya tout là dedans voilà donc je
maintenant tous les gens qui me disent
ah
est ce qu'il ya un endroit où je
pourrais trouver aux moddeurs leur dis
bah écoute est allé farfouiller là
dedans
peut-être que vous trouvez pas votre
bonheur directement dans le site est en
tout cas à force de voir des trucs ça
vous donnera peut-être des idées et où
une vocation non merci alors moi je
passais à la question suivante des plus
pratiques que faut-il penser les
promesses de l'hydrogène pour lutter
contre le changement climatique
climatique alors l'hydrogène c'est
j'espère que toutes les personnes qui
sont en train d'assister à ce webinaire
savent que ça n'est pas un élément natif
sur terre donc l'hydrogène est l'élément
le plus abondant de l'univers on en
trouve dans les étoiles pleins les
galaxies et c'est malheureusement là où
il se trouve en général il est jamais
très commode d'accès en celui qui est
dans le soleil est un peu loin puis pas
très commode à les tuyaux dans le soleil
pour compétir aux jeunes surtout qu'il
est sous forme de plasma c'est quand
même très commode
et l'hydrogène qui existe sur terre il
est toujours sous forme blier il y en a
plein dans l'eau mêlée sous forme liés
il y en a plein dans les hydrocarbures
mais il se forme liés et c'est donc
l'hydrogène en tant que tel comme il est
lié c'est pas une source d'énergie
on peut pas l'utiliser il n'y a pas de
différence de potentiel à exploiter dix
ans donc hydrogène et tout au plus un
vecteur c'est à dire que ça peut être
une manière de stocker et de transporter
d'énergie à partir du moment où on a eu
une autre source d'énergie pour obtenir
cette hydrolienne aujourd'hui la manière
dont on obtient d'hydrogène sur terre
c'est en réformant du méthane alors le
réformage de méthane c'est l'opération
qui consiste à mélanger du méthane ch4
la vapeur d'eau h2o
on chauffe tout ça très fort et on
obtient du co2 et d'hydrogène et
l'énergie de chauffage etc en général du
gaz
donc c'est une honte on sait très bien
faire de l'hydrogène sur terre ça me
pose strictement aucun problème sauf
qu'actuellement quand on fait de
l'hydrogène ont fait dix tonnes de co2
pour une pub d'hydrogène donc si le but
du jeu c'est d'avoir une source primaire
dans la nature déjà exploitables et en
plus dé carbonée mais malheureusement
sacoche aucune des deux cases c'est
carbonées et c'est pas dans la nature ça
peut devenir éventuellement un vecteur
concurrent d'électricité si on se met à
obtenir en hydrogène en électrolyse de
l'eau avec de l'électricité bas carbone
et à ce moment on est il faut faire des
calculs d'or de grandeur pour voir de
combien d'électricité on a besoin pour
remplacer quoi et surtout ça devient un
vecteur comme je le disais concurrent
d'électricité alors il a un avantage
c'est qui ce stock un peu plus facile
manqué l'électricité
il a un inconvénient c qui se transporte
beaucoup plus difficilement très
compliqué de transporter l'hydrogène
parce que l'hydrogène et le gaz qui a la
plus faible densité énergétique par
unité de volume de tous les gaz
combustible or cet affreux marriott nous
dit que l'énergie de transport d'un gage
d'indépendance de la nature du gaz
donc la déperdition énergétique pour
transporter de l'hydrogène est maximale
au sein de tous les gaz combustible on
peut imaginer quand on perd beaucoup
plus d'énergie rapporté à l'énergie
fille qu'on a qu'on a à l'arrivée quand
on transporte que l'hydrogène que quand
on transporte du méthane et a fortiori
du propane butane est encore à fortiori
du pétrole donc le dont je fais partie
des gens qui ne croient pas que
l'hydrogène va nous permettre de
remplacer les hydrocarbures
avec de l'électricité décarbonés et en
gardant une voiture d'une tonne et demie
par ménage je crois pas une seconde
par contre ce que les calculs dans de
grandes heures montre c'est que
l'hydrogène pourrait être intéressant
dans deux applications stationnaires
industriels qui sont d'une part la
fabrication des engrais les engrais des
bars avec la synthèse de l'ammoniac les
engrais azotés et l'ammoniac se
synthétise à partir de la zone de l'air
et d'hydrogène obtenu comme je viens
d'évoquer précédemment par réformage de
méthane
on pourrait très bien imaginer que cet
hydrogène soit obtenue par électrolyse
de l'eau
donc on est quelques réacteurs
nucléaires bélier qui font vibrer les
polices de l'eau et qui permet de
derrière de faire de l'ammoniac puis les
engrais il est le deuxième procédé qui
peut être intéressant et hydrogène c'est
la réduction du minerai de fer
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez on
réduit de minerai de fer si un ingénieur
des mines ne sais pas ça on réduit le
minerai de fer avec du charbon et du
carbone mais on pourrait très bien
imaginer réduire le minerai de fer avec
de l'hydrogène et du reste les suédois
viennent de signer un chèque l'état
suédois vient de remettre un chèque de
43 milliards d'euros si ma mémoire est
bonne sur la table pour lancer un énorme
projet pilote
vous savez que les suédois et le choix
des villes de faire chez eux un huissier
doit former habitat lurgi c'est pour ça
que c'est un pays industriel et le don
qu'ils ont ils ont un projet de
réduction du minerai de fer à
l'hydrogène
ça c'est quand on regarde les ordres de
grandeur sa flotte
c'est à dire que ça ça fait sens de
s'imaginer qu'on pourrait faire ce genre
de choses
les applications mobiles je suis
extrêmement perplexe et je pense que les
enfants mourront que on n'aura toujours
pas remplacé une fraction significative
du milliard de voitures sur terre on
n'aura toujours pas remplacé façon
significative du pétrole par de
l'hydrogène
merci on en a plein d'autres questions
sur les questions d'enseignement
alain guy rappelle qu' il ya une option
biotech aux mines qui existe depuis
longtemps que ce qu'il a subi il ya plus
de 30 ans moi je l'avais suivi aussi en
partie et c'est vrai que c'était très
très bien ma remarque c'était de se dire
que peut-être d'ailleurs ça devrait
faire partie d'un pack de cours
obligatoires je bats ma réflexion
c'était de se dire c'est finalement très
bizarre qu'un ingénieur ne naît pas des
fondamentaux aussi
en matière de biologie pour justement
décrypter des phénomènes qui sont quand
même différent des cela physique pas si
tu es partie du package de des notions
de base sur les écosystèmes
tout à fait d'accord partie parce que
parce que c'était une logique différente
pour avoir managé dans une de mes vies
précédentes aussi des des équipes de
chercheurs dans différents secteurs
disciplinaires on voit bien que un
physicien ne raisonne pas comme un comme
quelqu'un comme un biologiste qui ne
raisonne pas comme un acousticien et
dargaud que bon il ya des ja des champs
disciplinaires et je trouve que c'est
vrai que c'est la force d'un ingénieur
d'être capable de générer généralistes
d'être capable d'appréhender justement
les fondamentaux de de ces différentes
disciplines
alors il ya une question de 2 alors
est-ce que c'est françois françois lobit
ton je sois tu dis n'y at il pas aussi a
ajouté un enseignement de méthodes
nouvelles pour résoudre des problèmes
complexes complexe au sens de multi
disciplines justement la démarche est en
plastique ne peut pas s'appliquer mais
plutôt prendre des méthodes emprunté à
la sociologie précédent bonjour à tous
et toutes
et merci pour cette intervention dans ma
question c'est que moi j'étais ingénieur
et j'ai eu des démarches au début dans
mon parcours d'entreprise avec une
démarche très logique d'essayer de
résoudre des problèmes et plus j'avance
dans mon expérience c'est plus je
m'aperçois que on a affaire les
problèmes complexes qui nécessitent non
plus une résolution comme une équation
mais plutôt d'avoir une approche où il
faut inventer de nouvelles choses se
mettre un peu en dehors de l'équation la
regarder il ya des techniques comme ça
et quand je vois les sujets de
développement durable je les trouve
éminemment complexe et il veut demande
s'il tombe il n'y a pas apporté une
entame de méthodes scientifiques ou
justement de nom scientifique des armes
ou aux ingénieurs d'aujourd'hui si c'est
évident la première chose que je dis à
mes élèves quand je démarre mon cours
c'est de leur dire vous avez été
sélectionné pour entrer dans cette école
en étant capable de résoudre des
problèmes qui contiennent toute
l'information nécessaire même si elle
est bien cachée et qui n'admettent
qu'une seule solution
la vie ça va être essentiellement des
problèmes posés de travailleurs et qui
admettre plusieurs solutions ou une
infinité de solutions etc
c'est la première chose que je leur dis
avant de démarrer mon cours et je le
redis et mon coup on va être un des cas
d'école de ce que vous allez rencontrer
dans la vraie vie où vous avez des
problèmes qui sont par essence mal posée
par exemple l'arbitrage générationnel en
ce qui concerne le changement climatique
joint hier très vite ou bien pas jouir
et attendre patiemment pour canet pour
les autres il n'y a pas de vérité
scientifique là dedans c'est juste c'est
un choix c'est d'abord aller quelque
part
est ce qu'il ya une bonne manière de
poser ce problème au regard de la
science non il ya une bonne manière
d'éclairer scientifiquement le débat ça
oui mais il n'y a pas de manière de
résoudre scientifiquement ce problème
donc le oui je suis tout à fait d'accord
je suis tout à fait d'accord
une des suggestions que j'avais fait
alors il paraît que ça existe maintenant
à une époque était de dire que ça serait
peut-être malin alors je sais que ça
existe au niveau du corps des villes
puisque j'encadre en ce moment une
doublette du corps qui vont devoir
bosser avec une dizaine des dark donc
mais une des possibilités ça serait que
les sujets qu'il ya des espèces de
sujets de les mémoires ou les sujets de
recherche
il n'ya pas les stages en entreprise
mais les équivalents mémoire soit fait
de manière transdisciplinaire
c'est à dire que l'on colle dans une
belle équipe un élève des mines
un élève
de l'agro un délai le juriste c'est
pourquoi et on leur demande de plancher
ensemble sur un même problème
voilà enfin mais en tout cas alors je
sais pas si ça correspond enfin en tout
cas c'est dans l'esprit de la question
qui a été posée
c'est à dire c'est à prendre d'abord à
aa
le raisonnement de l'autre c'est à dire
ne pas forcer les gens à entrer
nécessairement dans son raisonnement
mais comprendre comment on peut soit
rentré dans le raisonnement de quelqu'un
d'autre même si on pense qu'on a quelque
chose à lui apporter c'est un sujet et
être être capable de regarder un
problème je voulais facettes diverses
justement de commencer à apprendre cette
capacité à résoudre des problèmes
complexes qui comme tous les moyens
complexes sont toujours en général posé
de travailleurs une manière incomplète
merci il ya plusieurs d'entre vous qui
avait posé des questions sur la
démographie messieurs en question
notamment par exemple de délais ni la
joggeuse qui dit est ce que la
démographie n'est pas la première
sciences du développement durable hélène
si tu veux commenter
merci je sais pas si je m'entends bien
ben voilà c'est ma question je pense que
moi j'ai remarqué que dans plusieurs
conférences sur le développement durable
dès qu'on pose cette question
les gens se sentent mis en cause
personnellement par rapport à dison
leurs projets familiaux donc ce qu'ils
ont vendu beaucoup d'enfants et trouve
que c'est pas un problème et puis s'ils
en ont moins il accepte d'examiner la
situation donc
ben voila je pense que c'est quand même
la croissance de la population qui tire
la croissance de la consommation en
première approche
voilà donc voilà qu est-ce qu en parle
ce genre marqué est ce que là aussi
moi j'ai pas du tout deux notions de ces
sujets là est-ce que c'est amérique très
peu les ingénieurs et un peu plus de
notions comme on l'a dit là c'est le
vivent des êtres humains ça peut être
important et ça rejoint la question de
famille olivier un avenir durable est
possible sans exigence sans envisager la
décroissance et où une baisse encourager
la démographie je vous avais fait y'a
pas longtemps un petit calcul où j'avais
constaté que les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre par personne
figurez vous que tout ce qu'elles ont
quand je vais tout ensemble à la
déforestation le métal etc et bien en
l'espace d'un siècle et demi c'est à
dire entre 1870 et le début des moments
pas de des statistiques dont je dispose
et 2020
là tout ce qu'elles ont fait ces deux
doublés or on est on est aujourd'hui en
moyenne mondiale 8 tonnes équivalent co2
par personne et en 1860
on était à quatre alors dans ces 4
l'essentiel c'était de la déforestation
et du méthane en 1860 distant 60 les
états unis défaut reste à tour de bras
les européens ont fini il ya d'autres
zones géographiques où ça commence aussi
significative la déforestation a suivi
la croissance démographique 1 de manière
très claire c'est on a coupé des forêts
pour faire des champs et le méthane
c'était les animaux de trait et puis les
rizières parce que ça fait quand même un
moment que la chine et à ses peuples et
donc le donc oui le premier déterminant
de très très loin de l'augmentation de
la pression humaine sur l'environnement
c'est la démographie c'est absolument
évident donc un des éléments ça c'est
aussi un truc que je dis avait
et d'élèves parcours une des facettes du
développement durable alors je le dis de
manière un peu en cas triste c'est de
s'occuper du planning familial tout à
fait claire alors il ya maintenant je
peux me retrancher en termes de caution
morale derrière quelqu'un qui est de ce
point de vue beaucoup plus respectable
que moi j'fais dit exactement la même
chose en l'occurrence gaël giraud quand
il était prêtre jésuite quand il était
chef économiste de l'afd avait dit que
la totalité de l'aide au développement
française si on voulait être un peu
sérieux sur la question du climat
devrait aller à trois choses et 3
seulement qui sont dans le power band
des femmes
c'est à dire la capacité des femmes à
disposer de leur destin de leur corps et
de la dune place dans la société
dans les pays d'intervention parce que
l'observation montre que à chaque fois
qu'ils augmentent avec reese de leur
destin elles font moins d'enfants
la deuxième chose c'est la mise en place
de systèmes de solidarité parce que
quand on n'a pas de système de
solidarité type chômage retraite ont
fait 25 enfants pour l'action qu'il y en
a un qui s'occupe de soi quand on sera
vieux ou si on est malade et puis la
troisième chose à faire c'est évidemment
l'accès aux moyens de contraception
c'est qu'après ça qui est un prêtre
jésuite qui disait ça je suis pas loin
de penser la même chose
c'est à dire que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il ya effectivement on n'ose pas aborder
de front le débat sur la démographie
c'est évident que la planète est
surpeuplée j'ose le dire
c'est à dire qu'elle ne peut pas
aujourd'hui en état stable accueillir 8
milliards d'êtres humains dont la moitié
sont des pâtes moyenne ça tient pas dans
la durée
c'est absolument évident donc ou bien on
restera milliards le niveau de vie dans
une planète qui se stabilise sera très
en dessous du niveau
vie des classes moyennes aujourd'hui en
termes de biens matériels série de trois
qui disent un moral et puis ou bien on
essaye de faire en sorte d'être un peu
moins nombreux alors être un peu moins
nombreux rapidement c'est très
désagréable s'appelle des maladies des
familles et des guerres pas ça mais par
contre si on peut éviter d'être encore
plus nombreux très vite c'est évident
que c'est toujours bon à prendre
donc oui la démographie est un vrai
sujet dans cette affaire c'est un sujet
très très difficile
dans une interview il ya un ou deux ans
j'avais dit exactement ce que je viens
de dire là et puis j'avais également
posé une question avant le coc vide mais
que le coc vide nous pose brutalement
aujourd'hui qui est est ce que dans
l'arbitrage de l'allocation des moyens
c'est les gens en fin de vie qu'il faut
privilégier la toute fin alors en ce
moment on est en train de donner la
réponse est oui c'est peut-être une
réponse respectable je suis pas en train
de dire que c'est pas ça qu'il faut
faire
par contre ce que je suis en train de
dire c'est que c'est ça qu'on est en
train thur et le et je pense que dans un
monde où les moyens son contingent
c'est une question à laquelle ont
malheureusement on pourra de moins en
moins échappé
on a des gros débat sur le chat 1 sur
pas mal de sujets les donc cette
question évidemment d'une approche sur
la décroissance il ya des questions qui
reviennent aussi sur l'hydrogène
dès qu'il s'agit bien sûr la démocratie
ce qui est très difficile et à mon avis
là ou alors là c'est pas un boulot
d'ingénieurs mais ce qui est très pas le
boulot d'ingénieurs c'est que tenir les
comptes ce qui est pas le boulot
d'ingénieurs c'est de savoir ce qu'on en
fait derrière moi ce que j'ai coutume de
dire pour finir ce débat là c'est que de
toute façon je pense qu'on n'échappera
pas à une diminution significative de la
population humaine dans la durée la
seule question est de savoir si ça peut
attendre dossier avec lui trois siècles
ou si malheureusement ça va nous tomber
dessus de manière plus brutale avant
parce que la boîte de pétri
quand son substrat s'épuise il ya
malheureusement les bactéries mesures
visent pas donc je sache je ne sais pas
j'ai pas la réponse je suis pas très
pressé que ça se termine en boucherie
j'ai deux enfants vraiment pas pressé
mais par contre ce dont je suis
absolument persuadé c'est que à trop
vouloir éviter ce débat je ne suis pas
sûr que on opte pour la situation la
plus stable possible pour l'avenir
ça me paraît à peu près évident michèle
morère demande quelle différence y at-il
dans ton propos jean marc et ceux de
prophètes de la décroissance comme
thomas malthus holler niche dont toutes
les prévisions catastrophiques on ne
saurait des démentis par les faits alors
je n'ai pas j'ai lu les deux tiers du
livre de malthus et je ne suis pas
arrivé jusqu'au stade où il fait des
prévisions donc malheureusement je ne
peux pas répondre sur marcus ce que je
sais c'est que j'ai lu le rapport dit du
club de rome c'est à dire de lévi
strauss après en avoir entendu parler 25
fois par des gens qui disaient qu'ils se
sont toujours planté
alors je me suis dit bon je vais quand
même aller voir ce qu'ils racontent voir
s'ils sont plantés et la réponse c'est
qu'il se sent pas planter du tout donc
je ne suis pas complètement sûr que
malthus on me fasse pas dire des trucs
voilà en tout cas moi je ne suis pas
arrivé jusqu'au stade où on lui fait ou
mal tu dis des trucs qui aurait été
démentie par là par la suite ce qui me
paraît absolument évident et là je vois
pas en quoi on a besoin d'invoquer
d'actus c'est que une progression
exponentielle sur une terre qui ne fera
jamais plus de 13 mille kilomètres de
diamètre à un moment ça s'arrête tous
d'accord comme tu disais tout à l'heure
c'est souvent un sujet d'optimisation
sous contrainte et à jean-luc qui fait
ni opposition aussi andy dans l'art de
l'ingénieur c'est souvent de réconcilier
les dilemmes par exemple d'un côté il
faut réduire les coûts de l'autre côté
il faut monter la qualité il ya
énormément dilemme à résoudre dans ce
pot ont ce problème du réchauffement
climatique
du coup il pose la question jean marc as
tu mis au point une méthode à force de
réconcilier ces dilemmes
il n'y a pas de méthode miracle la seule
méthode c'est qu'il faut en parler
c'est à dire que en fait il sait ce que
je n'ai pas leur le fait de ne pas en
parler et le plus sûr moyen de n'aller
nulle part d'en parler et de compter
enfin pour moi c'est le jouer mais je
pense que la méthode que tu as mis en
place de bilan carbone elle et elle est
essentielle elle est tellement essentiel
que comme tu l'as dit elle a été du coup
reprise au niveau international mondial
maintenant c'est le credo que tout ce
qui se mesure s'améliore est ce que tu
crois pas que justement à travers le
fait d'une généralisation maintenant une
meilleure compréhension du cycle du
carbone à travers le physique mais aussi
le vivant en étant capable de déployer
ce type d approche à la fois rigoureuse
pragmatique en partie conventionnelle
parce que il faut aussi réussir à le
construire ensemble
est-ce que ça c'est pas aussi un
mécanisme qui peut permettre de résoudre
oui alors c'est nécessaire mais pas
suffisant si je prends un parallèle
économique tenir une comptabilité c'est
nécessaire pour savoir qu'on a un
résultat net positif mais c'est pas
suffisant pas parce qu'on tient une
comptabilité qu'on arrive lui paraît
positif
voilà par contre si on tient là je me
réjouis
on peut pas savoir si le résultat net
est positif ou négatif voilà c'est
exactement pareil
la comptabilité carbone c'est pas elle
n'est pas auto déterminant de la
direction qu'on va prendre
par contre sans comptabilité carbone on
est à la veille
donc oui bien sûr qu'il faut compter
donc le et quand je disais tout à
l'heure le métier de l'ingénieur n'est
pas de trancher les débats sociétaux qui
relève au fond de choix moraux éthiques
etc
il est de les éclairer les éclairer ces
notamment compté alors sur la
comptabilité carbone je voudrais quand
même mettre un bémol
aujourd'hui nous sommes encore très très
loin de compter au niveau auquel il
faudrait compter pour être capable
d'éclairer toutes les décisions qu'on
prend dans un monde dans lequel on
serait vraiment sérieux sur la question
du climat la comptabilité carbone elle
serait presque aussi granulaire que la
comptabilité économique tout à l'heure
lors étant la question qui est posée il
ya réduire les coûts c'est évident
qu'aujourd'hui toute personne qui
cherche à réduire les coûts connaît le
le montant en euros du moindre stylo
qu'il achète il connaît absolument pas
le montant en carbone du mois rostino
qu'ils achètent donc s'il veut faire un
arbitrage euros contre carbonne
il est incapable de le faire si on va
être capable de faire est ce que c'est
parce que justement la grosse révolution
à venir de d'être capable de tout ce
flux est complètement à l'aise avec le
coup alors les choses dame a mené
aujourd'hui avec le coût des choses dans
ma petite expérience c'est que ça
n'arrivera jamais avec des engagements
volontaires seraient faux clé dans la
pause
l'état impose la comptabilité des
entreprises les gens qui ne tiennent pas
de comptabilité peuvent aller en prison
encore un défaut de tenues comptabilité
ses pédales donc tant qu'on ne sera pas
là pour la comptabilité carbone est bien
la comptabilité carbone ne se déploiera
pas au niveau auquel il faut la déployer
pour être capable d'en faire un
instrument d'arbitrage du quotidien donc
si l'état veut être vraiment sérieux
donc si monsieur macron voulait être
vraiment sérieux sur l'environnement il
ferait pas une réforme constitutionnelle
il le ferait une réforme tout juste
législatives en expliquant que les
entreprises sont tenues de publier tous
les ans leur compte carbone un niveau
aussi granulaire que les euros et si
elles font pas ça le chef d'entreprise
en taule
voilà qui ferait ça il a pas besoin de
changer la constitution et ça ferait
beaucoup plus pour la question
environnementale que de mettre
l'environnement dans la constitution
en tout cas sur ce serait un beau sujet
qui effectivement referais le lien entre
le monde physique et le monde économique
de mettre sur le même plan
cette capacité à compter le poids des
choses par dix présente évidemment on
capte ce carbone
on peut pas faire d'arbitrage sinon
directement vient parfaire d'arbitrage
et si on fait ça mon estimation c'est
que ça coûte quelques pour cent du
budget haïti n'importe quelle entreprise
mais surtout c'est une nouvelle langue
je pense que c'est une cape à stimuler
appréhender une manière nouvelle
ce poids sur l'environnement j'avais
publié il ya un an
rien
à tribune alors qu'ils concernaient le
monde financier mais en fait ça concerne
le monde économique dans son ensemble
dans lequel j'avais expliqué qu' une
entreprise sérieuse est une entreprise
qui a minima fait les deux choses
suivantes
c'est une entreprise qui inflige à
l'ensemble de ses cadres 20 heures de
cours ou au hasard sur la compréhension
réchauffement du climat sur la
compréhension des enjeux énergie climat
et qui par ailleurs déploie une
comptabilité carbone qui est aussi
traduit leur faim qui descend jusqu'aux
centres de décisions délégué j'ai envie
de dire raisonnablement pas est donc
acquis l'entreprise à qui ça coûte
quelques pourcents s'engager à haïti et
toute entreprise qui ne fait pas ça peut
bien se déclarer notre verte responsable
dur à bouger pas quoi à titre personnel
je n'écoute même pas je considère que
c'est juste des mots et que ça n'a
strictement aucune valeur pour le moment
j'en connais pas beaucoup qui font ça
donc je peux en témoigner de 2,2
jean-marc donc moi je au sein des gee je
suis pas sûr que c'est le niveau
granulaire aussi précis que de celui que
tu donnes mais vraiment il ya un énorme
effort de formation l'ensemble des
collaborateurs et ensuite évidemment non
seulement d'avoir des objectifs de
réduction d'empreinte carbone mais
effectivement démesurée parce que faut
dire qu'on est quand même concerné quand
on est un des acteurs de l'énergie et je
peux citer aussi le cas de gecina qui
est la première foncière de bureaux
je désire dans son conseil
d'administration et qui a mis en en
place 1 1
en fait un prix carbone interne pour y
rajoute à tous les projets internes le
poids carbone pour être capable
effectivement progressivement d'inciter
les l'ensemble des collaborateurs à
trouver les solutions pour baisser cet
impact carbone de l'immobilier qui ne
développe et gère rénove et c'est donc
je pense que pour l'instant c'est la
sphère de pionnier enfin de quelques
entreprises
peut-être sans doute de centaines d
jamais mélanger comme tu dis c'est sans
doute que ça se généralise et devient
absolument banal un lit de connaître son
pack à banias oui à un niveau où c'est
totalement généralisé dans les
opérations du quotidien
à moins que quelques centaines alors
damien il y avait une petite question
pratique dans votre chat chez désolé on
va pas pouvoir reprendre toutes les
questions parce que vous avez été elles
sont nombreuses et encore des nouvelles
et désamorcer un qui a une petite
question pratique exactement mais c'est
peut-être justement quels sont tes
conseils pourront connaître son propre
feu pour pouvoir faire simplement son
bilan carbone personnel je dirais
puisque je vois que la question
personnelle alors on a un bilan carbone
personnel est un sujet qui m'a intéressé
assez vite derrière le bien c'est
bertrand voit la paire tranche pas si tu
te poser des questions bertrand je
lèverai jean-marc elle est bien oui
c'est tout à fait ça je préfère mon
bilan carbone personnel voir quels sont
les progrès que j'ai à faire et comment
et comment je mets le jeu mu aurait
évidemment tout peut-être tous les boss
il faut faire tous les mois tous les ans
et voir les progrès qui sont réalisés
ils ont vraiment global et chercher au
niveau du site de l'ademe
il ya plusieurs mois que je suis très
motivé très intéressés par ce sujet mais
j'ai rien trouvé maintenant ils disent
y'a plus rien
c'était un peu un peu déçu donc je
cherche dans le le calculateur
d'empreinte carbone personnel et quelque
chose qui va moins intéressé très vite
derrière le leader carbone du court et
dans le cadre d'une association que j'ai
contribué à créer qui s'appelle avenir
climatique qui existe toujours
j'ai j'avais mis au point effectuée à
effet développé par un stagiaire un
calculateur de bilan carbone personnel
enfin à l'époque il était incomplet il
n'a pas été très bien maintenu bref
tombé dans les oubliettes
il ya eu d'autres initiatives il ya un
truc qui s'appelle micmac aujourd'hui
d'avenir climatique qui existe et au
sein de carbone 4 récemment on a relancé
ce projet là enfin vous cette direction
là avec un outil qui s'appelle my si au
tout est en fait un truc dont on s'est
rendu compte à l'expérience c'est que
pour qu'un calculateur d'empreinte
carbone personnel ainsi que les gens à
passer à l'action derrière
en fait il y avait un truc tout con
qu'il fallait faire c'est qu'il fallait
faire faire ce calcul en groupe c'est à
dire que quand les gens sont seuls chez
eux et qui font le qui font le calcul
alors ils font peut-être une
éventuellement il tombe de leur chaise
et puis derrière rien de le dire ils
sont chez eux ils vont pas commencer à
expliquer qu'ils vont déménager demain
matin et quelques petits aménagements à
la marge tu peux faire est globalement
parce qu'un truc qui est absolument
essentiel dans ce qui concerne la
psychologie des hommes c'est que comme
on est des animaux sociaux on aime bien
se déplacer en groupe c'est pour ça que
financiers font faillite tous en même
temps c'est pas ce que je fait
d'appartenir à un groupe qui a ses codes
et plus important que le fait d'avoir
raison tout seul
donc quand on est dans un groupe au
moment où on découvre son empreinte
carbone et qu'on peut la comparer avec
celle d'autres et on peut commencer à
discuter de ce qui est facile et pas
facile à faire pour réduire en fait
l'expérience montre que les gens passent
plus facilement à l'action que quand on
découvre le truc tout seul dans son coin
donc on a mis au point un outil qui
s'appelle mal si au tout mais qui ne
diffuse que à travers de l'équivalent de
réunions tupperware
c'est à dire que en fait on découvre
l'outil en étant accompagné par
quelqu'un et au sein d'une audience où
il ya d'autres personnes qui découvrent
l'outil puis derrière il ya un échange
est ce que c'est facile par facile de
faire ceci de faire cela et les gens qui
ont fait ce genre de chose une deux ou
trois fois preuve en est le devenir des
ambassadeurs il va se faire former pour
devenir ambassadeur et derrière à de
faire ce genre de chose ailleurs ce
principe de la réunion de paris voilà
donc ça s'appelle my si au tout et ça il
ya un site web qui doit être ici en tout
point fr pourquoi que ça ça ça se trouve
avec un bon moteur de recherche et on
peut s'inscrire donc c'est ça le
l'information importante ont fait
des conférences gratuites à destination
du grand public
on en fait évidemment pas aidé par jour
mais en donc on peut s'inscrire en ligne
un tout petit temps d'attentes mais
encore une fois l'intérêt c'est qu'on
participe à une expérience collective
quand on fait ce genre de truc c'est
beaucoup plus riche que de faire ça dans
son coin en particulier parce que
derrière les trucs et astuces pour
passer à l'action
son c'est beaucoup plus facile d'en
discuter
il ya un an la ds que tu l'a appliqué
avec les oleg mes élèves non mais je
pourrais en tout cas je pourrais je peut
le suggérer à damien puisque c'est lui
qui circule demande unités
d'enseignement j'ai deux camarades là
qui se soutiennent mutuellement pour
rappeler que dans le titre de la
visioconférence il y avait la question
du devoir d'obéissance ou de
désobéissance n'oublie pas ce terme la
dent dans le débat est donc jean marc
que voilà sur ce sujet de de ton côté
rebelle quels sont les sujets là quand
je rajoute dans la question mais s'il
marins ou pierre vous voulez intervenir
il ya en question particulier dans le
contexte de la fonction publique donc je
pense qu'il voulait explicité de le
contexte de la question donc je pense
que je vois à peu près la question
enfin je veux je peux l'entendre par
oral mais je pense que je vois pourquoi
les questions alors là cette réflexion
en face aux ce côté rebelle
il a démarré au moment où hollande s'est
fait élire en 2012
je me rappelle que dans sa campagne
j'avais été très énervé par son slogan
sur les 50% de nucléaire j'avais été
encore plus énervé par le fait que la
presse unanime n'avait à aucun moment
posé une question qui est quand même
tout qu'on sait que les constantes âge
allant jusqu'à 100 % si on fait 50% de
nucléaire avait coiffé donc votre moitié
de penser que un objet se termine à 100%
et j'ai trouvé extraordinaire que cette
question étant passés à la trappe dès
après l'arrivée de hollande au pouvoir
on a mis en place au sein de la dg est
qu un programme visant à baisser le
nucléaire sans qu'on se demande sans que
finalement sans qu'on sache vraiment
pourquoi on allait remplacer tas de gens
qui sont bien que ce poste à faire des
tas de scénarios en disant ça va marcher
sauf que peut-être que ça marchera pas
et alors à cette époque là je me suis
dit c'est quand même extraordinaire on a
pris les gens qui sont parmi les plus
brillants de cervelle du pays qui sont
capables de faire quoi la topologie
algébrique l'équation de schrödinger
et maintenant on leur demande de violer
des règles de trois est-ce qu'ils ont la
possibilité de dire non non je ferais
pas ça alors je me suis un peu renseigné
parce que je me suis parce que j'ai
toujours entendu dire que le
fonctionnaire devait obéir d'accord si
madame royal arrive en disant vous allez
peut-être caudry garde-à-vous ont fait
la connerie on discute pas surtout si
c'est vraiment donc le donc je me suis
posé la question est alors en fait j'ai
vu arriver qu'il ya une clause de
désobéissance du fonctionnaire ça existe
et le fonctionnaire non seulement à la
possibilité mais a le devoir de désobéir
à partir du moment où on lui donne un
ordre qui est manifestement contraire à
la loi
ou alors je n'en avais plus de la
formulation exacte mais il ya quelque
chose qui relève de l'intérêt supérieur
du pays enfin il ya quelque chose qui se
rapproche du fait de ne pas trahir
je n'en avais plus de la formulation
exacte eh bien je pense que dans les
circonstances actuelles
cette réflexion devrait très
sérieusement réactivée parce que je
considère que c'est un drame que des
gens qui ont une expertise technique
doivent être forcé de faire quelque
chose donc ils savent eux-mêmes que ça
ne peut pas mener au résultat escompté
je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut absolument éviter
d'abord parce que ça les rend
neurasthénique ou schizophrène
j'en connais est par ailleurs parce que
c'est pas du tout dans l'intérêt du pays
que d'avoir pris des membres ayant pour
leur demander de faire des trucs dont on
sait à l'avancé ça marchera pas là c'est
toi c'est ton avis personnel parce que
campagne de démission mais massif c'est
peut-être que certains considèrent que
ça tout bien pesé ça doit être quand
même possible de faire 50 points c'est
un génie c'est drôle pour l'hydraulique
et l'éolien et evry reprend avec chacun
d'entre vous les promesses qui ont été
faites en 2012 et on regarde ce qui
s'est passé évidemment pas ça qui s'est
passé déjà on a dit 50% de nucléaire en
2025 on a dit que finalement ce sera
2035 qu'en fait ce sera pas 2035
on a dit wen réseau va être stable ou et
ouais ça va pas coûter cher rien aucune
de ses promesses n'a été satisfaite et
on le savait depuis le départ on va
développer les géants français
américains français allemands du soleil
à la pluie un seul aucune des promesses
n'a été tenue
c'est très simple aucune donc le c'était
facile de le dire à l'avancé facile mais
il n'ya pas que ça je pourrais prendre
un autre exemple qui est la
libéralisation des infrastructures
régaliennes c'est exactement le même
genre de conneries c'est à dire on sait
à l'avancé que un truc qui gère sur le
siècle ne peut pas être décidée sur la
base du prix de marché de la semaine
dernière on le sait c'est un truc tout
le monde c'est bon mais ça n'empêche pas
quand même de mettre d'état brillante
cervelle au service de cette chimère
donc je pense que alors effectivement
c'est les convictions je pense quand
même que le fait de se dire à
fonctionnaire n'a jamais eu à discuter
de la pertinence de ce qu'on lui demande
même quand c'est une connerie manifeste
je pense que l'heure est révolu
d'accepter ce genre de choses parce que
dans le monde infini on peut accepter
ses erreurs donc finalement au fond on
nous demande de faire une connerie mais
c'est pas très grave un monde infini
d'erreur est réversible et dans le monde
finit l'erreur n'est pas réversible
d'erreur ce nobel est un appel à
l'éthique personnelle internement
effectivement qu'on est quand même
chacun libre de démissionner si on
trouve des demandes des choses très
bizarres ou oasis
après 12,6 à changer leur dit non non je
ferais pas ça non ils passent tout cas
d'exprimer sa position c'est très
important d'exprimer ses analyses et
d'être capable d'être dans un dialogue
comme tu disais tout à l'heure en
écharpe de miss aide à comprendre je
n'entendrai des accusés pour reparler du
même je pense qu'un type comme yves
martin tu es capable de dire non non je
ne fais pas ça alors peut-être qu'il l'a
payé du fait de deux bases sdg e lp mais
en tout cas je pense qu'ils étaient
capables de le faire et je pense que
l'époque aujourd'hui et exige je dis
bien exige on en revienne a
effectivement quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de l'éthique et après tout si
les politiques ont envie de se vautrer
dans la démagogie qu'il le fasse tout
seul mais je trouve que d'entraîner des
pays à la suite et quelque chose
aujourd'hui qui est c'est pas rendre
service à la génération qui nous suit
vraiment pas voilà donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas le débat
mérite d'être mené
donc moi je l'exprimé conviction qui est
la mienne évidemment je suis pas
fonctionnaire comme ça me va très bien
je suis prête elle vibre de faire la
morale aux épices d'autres peuvent avoir
des avis très différent c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu pas mal de rapports je pense que
tu contestes de ton côté
j'en ai d'autres gens qui voient des
dépositions et des solutions différentes
peut-être complémentaires d'ailleurs de
celle plus certaine que tu pousses mais
c'est sillage la totalité de leurs
économies s'ils ont fait que ça va
marcher
la joie bien six mois je vais la tête
sur le niveau de jeu pour tester leur
langue à réhabiliter et engagement petit
qui dit je souhaitais plus et sont si
vite rangé dans le véhicule
pourquoi ce ne serait pas la solution et
j'ai vu le danger n en reviens moi
peut-être qu'on peut reprendre un petit
peu
alors je vais vous de calcul d'heures de
douleur aujourd'hui on utilise en france
40 millions de tonnes de produits
pétroliers dans les transports
terrestres
si je voulais remplacer sa part de
l'hydrogène jeu devrait doubler la
capacité électrique du pays
je rajoute 500 térawattheures
d'électricité
juste avec des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires parce que le nucléaire c'est
caca berck il ya quelqu'un là autour du
webinaire là qui est d'accord engagé la
totalité de son héritage plus celui de
ses enfants plus et cetera sur le fait
qu'on va ya
et alors il ya aussi tout l'enjeu de la
baisse des consommations quand même y
aller sinon d'efficacité énergétique
on passe aux vélos électriques on a plus
besoin d'hydrogène pourquoi s'emmerder à
manipuler de l'hydrogène qui est un truc
qui est logistiquement est extrêmement
qui n'ont à gérer parce que c'est
dangereux parce que comme ça c'est un
type d' usage pour certains types d âge
en fait sans doute c'est peut-être dans
la question c'est de ne pas penser qu'il
ya une solution enfin en tout cas c'est
bien celui-là lé l'actionnaire aura
plusieurs solutions
je le redis on n'a pas le temps de gérer
ses peurs à trois degrés de
réchauffement c'est la guerre partout
donc on n'a pas le temps de faire et
cela c'est bien ça la sanction d'olive
la sanction de l'échec
elle est là c'est que ça sera la
barbarie partout faut pas se leurrer les
gens auront plus à bouffer donc on
parlera il faudrait que tu finisses
cette conférence qui était plutôt sur la
tonalité positive sur quelque chose de
plus positif le marxisme est positif
c'est refuser qu'on perde du temps aaa
savander voilà des pistes dont on sait
qu'elles sont condamnées à l'avance
parce qu'elles sont beaucoup trop risqué
que j'ai en tout cas le sentiment
d'urgence
et puis le l'analyse des soumissions qui
sont là ont fait un marin compta tempête
arrive il se démerde avec les moyens du
bord d'accord donc il n'est pas content
de voir arriver une tempête il n'est pas
du tout content il faudra ça drôle
mais en attendant il commence pas à se
dire bon alors une tempête arrive très
bien mais je vais mettre mes ingénieurs
de la r&d au travail et peut-être que un
moment d'hydrogène va permettre de faire
arriver un hélicoptère qui me sortira de
là pour me poser sur les mers lunaires
non vive fait les moyens du bord bon
voilà aujourd'hui il faut qu'on fasse
avec les moyens du bord dans les moyens
du bord ya pas de bons gènes dans toutes
les voitures ont fait pas avec les
moyens du bord voilà c'est il faut bien
comprendre que des réponses pour
aujourd'hui les accords de paris qu'on a
tous signés ont 12 etc
c'est un kobe de parents c'est à dire
c'est 5% de baisse des émissions tous
les angles on n'a pas le temps
d'attendre vingt ans que l'hydrogène
soit là dans 20 ans il faut déjà qu'on
ait perdu plus de la moitié de nos
émissions sans l'hydrogène donc
hydrogène sera peut-être je le redis ça
sera très bien pour faire des engrais
et de l'acier s'il y en a encore en rap
derrière on verra ce qu'on en fait mais
en attendant ça ira beaucoup plus vite
de remplacer une bonne partie des
bagnoles par des vélos électriques
plutôt que d'attendre angèle donc voilà
on connaît maintenant sa position je
marque sur effectivement le longe
d'euros tout cas d'agir vite d'agir
maintenant sans verser voudraient
également et des plus que le monde
puisqu'on va revenir la physique le
monde physique n'est pas linéaire
donc il ya une illusion linéaire dont il
faut absolument qu'on se défasse qui est
celle que les dégâts sont
proportionnelles à l'élévation de
température donc là on se dit on a pris
un degré moins 1 degré en vision vit
très bien et 2 degrés c'est pas deux
fois un degré c'est peut-être cents soit
1 degré en termes de cas de conséquences
et 3° c à 301 degrés c'est peut-être
mille fois un degré en termes de
conséquences à deux degrés par exemple
tous les cours sont morts à deux degrés
on met en route très vraisemblablement
la dislocation de l'antarctique de
l'ouest qui finira pas ramené six mètres
d'eau dans l'océan mondial
donc ça veut dire que la ville de
boulogne sur mer etc
enfin tout un alors c'est pas tout de
suite car à quelques siècles et quand
même à 4 degrés il ya deux à trois
milliards d'hommes qui vivent dans des
zones qui sont au jeu qui ce qu'ils
deviendront franchement inhabitable ses
terres que seront plus chaude que sa
première c'est évident qu'une planète
oui à 3 milliards de personnes qui
peuvent plus vivre là où elles vivent
physiquement et une planète barbares et
monstres tape dessus absolument évident
et on en a bien la crise syrienne
il ya un article qui vient de sortir
dans le proceedings of the national
academy of science aux des états unis
expliquant qu'elle aa déterminant
climatiques très clair donc essayer les
places et le place c'est pas greenpeace
qui sans ça le fait depuis ce morceau
donc le j'insiste vraiment sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une espèce de
torpeur
il faut qu'on ait le sentiment d'urgence
ça c'est un bel essai amené grand
message aujourd'hui et on l'a pas du
tout on n'avait pas avant de kobe et
puis tout d'un coup on était pris à
froid
méfions nous parce que changement
climatique ça va pas varier de manière
continue
ok merci le préfet bancaire christian
est-ce que voilà sandrine je pense qu'on
a déjà dépassé par rapport au timing
qu'on s'était fixés alors on a quelqu'un
qui demande si éventuellement vous
seriez prêt à répondre par mail à
quelques questions si vous voulez bien
je sais pas comment on peut faire ça
avant c'est compliqué alors j'ai une
recommandation neutre
pour ceux qui auront été un peu frustré
c'est de pouvoir suivre les cours de
jean marc que deux à l'école je crois
que ça existe sous forme de mouk donc en
tout cas il ya quelques vidéos bien fait
qui permettent aussi de voilà
d'appréhender les fondamentaux sur pas
mal de choses que tu a rappelé est en
tout cas c'est vrai que ce message
important d'urgence
et puis de dont je veux à trouver à
portée de développer des plats de
nouvelles solutions qui sont dans le
domaine économique sociétaux technique
je pense que ça c'est un message qui est
très partagée et est justement l'enjeu
pour l'école de d'être un acteur majeur
sur ces sujets là ça fait partie de
l'ambition que l'école s'est fixé et
donc le rôle de la fondation ça va être
deux pas de faire appel à vous tous ceux
qui souhaitent soutenir l'école dans cet
effort pour justement contribué de façon
importante déterminante
finalement en tant qu'école des mines de
paris un d'être une référence au service
de la corde paris permettre de résoudre
afin de répondre à ce défi du changement
climatique
donc merci à tous pour pour ces
questions les débats à merci et
jean-marc pour tes réponses franches
direct merci à sandrine et marie-alix
pour l'organisation de cette conférence
et puis parce que je crois sandrine de
ton contrôle que tout ça est avaient été
enregistrés ceux qui veulent le revoir
en replay ou n'ont pas pu participer en
direct le revoir et surtout merci encore
de votre participation et continuer le
dialogue pour trouver effectivement
construire ensemble les solutions
s'engager dans dans ce domaine complexe
mais c'est pour ça que ça besoin
d'ingénieurs mobiliser engagé prêt à
dialoguer même si ça fait pas toujours
plaisir et qu'on ne naît pas à tous
d'accord au départ
l'enjeu c'est d'être engagé dans
l'action et comme tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure je remarque que l'action c'est
ça qui nine qui fait du bien et qui
apporte justement non seulement des
solutions mais mais voilà qui nous fait
grandir
il trouvait préparer c'est l'avenir pour
les générations futures donc à finir par
une note optimiste quand même le
remarque pas in fine je pense que cette
affaire-là est une opportunité pour
notre pays
quand on regarde un petit peu ce qu'a
été l'histoire de la france et
l'histoire de ces de ses compétences
on se rend compte que la france à être
toujours historiquement très bonnes aux
deux extrémités du spectre de l'activité
économique
on est très bon dans les talents
individuels donc on fait des très bons
couturier cuisinier architectes etc
on est totalement nulle dans le pays
donc quand il s'agit de faire des
cuisinières dans une boîte de 2000
personnes ça on n'est pas bon et on
redevient très bon quand il s'agit de
faire des très grands systèmes complexes
on a fait des avions d un système
hospitalier qui marche très bien quand
enfin je veux dire quand on regarde par
rapport à l'essentiel des autres pays
dans le monde
un système ferroviaire qui marche
extrêmement bien système électrique qui
marche avant qu'on nous ait décidé de
couper en petits bouts et qui marche
moins bien mais l'avant il marche très
bien et je pense que donc il ya une
spécificité qui est qui est une force
française qui est la planification à
large échelle le système complexe
or il se trouve que la façon de sortir
par le haut de cette affaire de
changement climatique demande de la
planification à large échelle de
systèmes complexes
donc moi j'ai envie de dire faut pas
avoir peur du problème parce que c'est
une chance pour nous français dans un
monde dans lequel et quand on regarde
les ingénieries dans le monde
il ya toujours des français qui ont été
sur les trois premières marches du
podium dans énormément de domaines même
si c'est pas bien de dire du bien du
pétrole ici technip et schlumberger ces
français systra c'est la plus grosse
ingénierie ferroviaire dans le monde ces
français dans l'eau évidemment on a deux
géants on les connaît tous ces français
etc
donc je pense que cette affaire de
changement climatique il faut le voir
nous français comme un défi à relever
mais qui nous est favorable parce que ça
demande une manière d'approcher les
problèmes qui est qui relève des forces
historiques de la france
donc moi je pense que non seulement il
faut pas en avoir peur
mais il faut pas avoir peur de ce jeudi
il faut pas avoir peur nous jeter dans
le bain bon ça va l'eau est un peu
froide
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas que ça passe
un long chemin de roses mais je pense
que sur le long terme ça serait une
erreur que la france ne se jette pas à
corps perdu dans la construction de la
décarbonation de l'économie parce que je
pense que c'est un domaine dans lequel
on tirera les marrons du feu
mieux que les autres mais pour ça il
faut sortir du village gaulois c'est ce
que j ai tout faire et il faut accepter
de se retrouver autour d'un objectif
commun mais je pense que si on y arrive
on a une vraie chance
merci jean marc de cette tonalité pour
courtier raymond dernier chapeau je
rajouterais que la france est aussi pays
qui a inventé le système métrique qu'il
a développée au niveau international
donc peut-être qu'avec le bilan carbone
qui aura aussi permis de cette
réinvention nouveau système métrique clé
on les défis du 21e siècle
donc même encore merci à tous et à très
bientôt pour poursuivre ses dialogues
sur le développement durable